alright switching gears now I just want
you to know I had permission to hug
Lonnie by the way he gave me permission
to touch it Joe Biden joking in his
first public appearance after several
women have accused him of unwanted
touching right after the speech Biden
answered questions about those
allegations well you know I wouldn't be
surprised but I've had hundreds and
hundreds of people contact me and who I
don't know and you know say the exact
opposite I'm not sorry for any of my
intentions I'm not sorry for anything
that I have ever done I've never been
disrespectful intentionally and
president Trump is weighing in he's
trolling Biden on Twitter with this
parody video I think as I hug people I
grabbed men with my shoulders is that
you can do this and women know it's the
way of all did this way I've tried to
show and care about them and risk the
former vice president quickly responded
by calling Trump quote presidential as
always what do you make of this Emily I
feel like today we saw the old Biden and
the kind of new Biden and he shined in
my opinion in front of that Union
audience right where he kind of
exhibited what propelled him to success
in the past which was you know it very
relatable and comfortable and hey we're
all and we're all in the same boat
making that joke and then afterward
during that presser I was just struck by
what I felt was him him being archaic he
seemed to me like a relic where he said
it you know the definition of
progressive progressive it seems to be
changing almost confused and it seemed
that while it might resonate with older
voters in the Democratic Party it didn't
seem to me that he had that relevance
that I can see that could galvanize the
entire spectrum of the Democratic Party
which is what would be needed for him to
win the primary I thought he was
seemingly sadly out of touch that's
interesting
Jesse you know I noticed all week that
Republicans have been in his corner on
this saying maybe the meat hashtag me
two movements gone too far so I'm
thinking myself wow it's not interesting
is it the case that Republicans may want
Joe Biden maybe a little bit nicked up
and damaged as a foil for Trump in 2020
yeah we like to see the Democrats
damaged if they're gonna run against
Trump that's obvious but I think the
Biden handled himself well today there
was a nice icebreaker at the top the
joke and then when he did the gaggle I
thought he seemed relaxed and confident
and tried to make sure everybody
understood he was not being perverted
and that's what I think needs to come
across that he's just maybe a little
archaic as you would say or goofy but he
did struggle when he was trying to
define ideologically where he was
progressive moderate Democrat he finally
stuck the landing and said I'm an
obama/biden Democrat and I think that's
where he needs to stay but he's moving
right now into the Elizabeth Warren
territory where whatever she says
doesn't matter everybody just thinks
fake Indian and now if you get the
constant trickle of more women coming
out saying that he violated my personal
space week after week after week every
time you see Biden you don't think about
what he said in the speech you just
think creepy Joe huh so you know Dana
what strikes me here is that this opens
the door to a lot of questions about Joe
Biden's past obviously the Anita Hill
hearings would be large but also his
support for business the fact that he
opposed partial-birth abortion as it's
called for a while the plagiarism
charges against him I guess that's 30
years ago he supported the Iraq war Yeah
right nice summary one that was good
telling people the fact people like okay
Juan shut up remember in 2008 what was
the deal between McCain and Obama McCain
had this really long record and Obama
was like hope and change and if you look
at what's happening now with the
Democrats they might love Joe Biden
and they might think you know he's the
he could be the best candidate but he
has all of these things that a new
democratic party doesn't want but then
we all say that on this show but every
single time the polling comes out about
Biden we talk about all these things
that are gonna be hard for him but he
stays at the top and the Democratic
polls not close and it's not close I
don't he might ticket in now one other
thing is that because I know where
you're going with that and I agree the
in the Fox News voter analysis of 2016
whatever whatever we called it at that
point then one of the number one things
and all of those primary debates or and
the voting is that Republicans said we
liked him because Trump because he tells
it like it is we want someone who will
tell us like it is good thing I think
that Biden could do is tell him like it
is but he's not quite yet there all
right tire is one of the time did in the
speech to agree I love the joke you know
I thought it was great good for him yeah
like that's how you fight this on this
is it he's not being accused of sexual
harassment never taking somebody in a
back corner and being completely
inappropriate they're saying you know he
he I didn't like the way he hugged me or
congratulating me it's a different thing
there was a line there so good for him
to fight back with a joke and of course
it's always great to clearly not be
creepy when there's children present so
that was how that was really I thought
he had a good day I was I was proud of
him I was happy that he take it though
right look at put it in black and white
and ready Roy
that's right I think tires you gotta be
careful with your comments about
children when we had that picture up
there